i want this spider-man no way home
trailer sorry best i can do is another
eternal swan and about 25 shang-chi
featurettes welcome to the heavy spoiler
show i'm your host paul and though it
feels like we're eternally waiting for
our door to be fixed marvel are still
giving that goodness with a brand new
look at their upcoming film the eternals
in this video we're going to be breaking
down the trailer it's easter eggs hidden
details and also giving our thoughts on
what could be happening in the movie
there might be some spoilers here so if
you don't want anything ruined then i
recommend that you turn off now if you
enjoyed the video then please smash the
thumbs up button and don't forget to
subscribe for breakdowns like this each
and every day without the way thank you
for clicking this now let's get into our
breakdown of the eternals trailer
okay so the trailer itself actually
confirms a lot of the plot leaks that we
got earlier in the air in regards to
what happens in the movie these leaks
stay that the eternals were created by
the celestials in order to hunt
predators known as the deviants
according to what they said the deviants
basically feasted on newly formed
evolving worlds that had a sudden burst
of life and this explains why they show
up again after the snap we learn this
from ajac played by selma hayek who we
open the trailer on from the first
trailer we know that the eternals came
to earth millennia ago and that they
helped us to evolve they were sent here
in order to fight the deviants and after
meeting us decided that we're so damn
adorable that they had to stay got our
wars and stuff yeah but we've got our
memes as well now all of this was
heavily shown in the first trailer and
though they spent centuries together i
think it's safe to say that they decided
to split up and live a part on the
planet however the threat of the
deviants returning brings them together
and thus they have to team up once more
now interestingly we don't see ajak in
any more of the present day scenes in
the trailer every time she shows up it
seems to be in either a flashback or a
scene that's set in an earlier part of
the timeline this could mean that icarus
kills her and later on in the trailer we
see him at her house firing his eye
lasers i actually have a theory that
icarus is bad and that he's angered over
falling out of love with cersei played
by gemma chan in the first look the pair
were together for a long time but then
they broke up and it is rumored that
cersei will now be dating dane whitman
played by kit harrington this whole idea
of them falling out was teased at in a
recent interview for the film in which
nate moore and chloe zhao told
entertainment weekly the following it's
a little bit like being on a road trip
with nine of your closest friends for 7
000 years in development we joke that
it's like if tony stark and steve rogers
lived together for that long that
friendship will turn into frenemies and
then turn into enemies and then come
back to friendship because you have that
common bond it's like a family no vin
diesel so this idea of the group
splitting up is definitely mirrored in
them perhaps icarus summons the deviants
in order to bring them to earth and he
kills ajak in order to stop this info
getting out going off on a massive side
tangent there i'm probably wrong but
that's just the vibe i get now let's
focus on more on the trailer than my
stupid ramblings now ajax mentions
thanos and how the snap blossoming the
population is what caused an energy
spike to let the deviants return this
sent a gigantic asteroid to earth which
caused the tsunami and the rise of the
villains on our planet the eternals now
have seven days in order to stop them
and this idea of the world being
destroyed in the space of a week of
course juxtaposes the bible which said
that god created the heavens and earth
in the same time period however there
will be seven days of destruction and
this idea of seven is further mirrored
in the fact that the eternals came to
earth 7000 years ago let me know if i'm
reaching now we see more inside of their
ship and what i'm guessing is the
prologue in the central communication
device is a hologram of a celestial who
i'm guessing is sending them on their
mission to our planet now it was said in
the leaks that the eternals themselves
are actually highly advanced artificial
intelligence and that the group are
actually machines rather than people
this is seemingly confirmed in the first
look as we can see a power orb passing
into ajax's neck which seemingly
activates her the celestials themselves
are very machine-like and i'm guessing
that they built the eternals as the next
step in their evolution now in our last
video we discussed a lot of the plot
elements for the movie including how the
eternals themselves had been created by
the celestials and i got a lot of heat
for it with people saying i was wrong
they said they'd thumbs down the video
and kill me and my family and this is
because their origin story changed up
massively from the comics however i do
think this moment seems to suggest
that i was actually right on that which
is a rare occasion now they travel
across our solar system and fly right
next to our sun which doesn't melt the
ship showing how strong it is we get
more of the ancient fishing village
which was shown in the first trailer and
learned that the eternals were
protectors of humanity chloe zhao said
that unlike most of the previous marvel
movies that she really wanted to shoot
as much as possible on location marvel
movies often get criticized for being
very dependent on green screens i think
you can really tell in this first look
that they've done something different as
the settings are great and the
authenticity that comes across in the
scenes looks absolutely fantastic these
moments early on are clearly being told
by cersei to dane who knows nothing jon
snow now damon dane actually goes on to
become the black knight but whether he's
in the film as this character or not
remains to be seen i think the most
likely thing is that they'll set him up
in this movie as the black knight and
that he'll appear in future films as the
character now he asks a big question
that several fans had which is where the
heckings were you guys when thanos was
snapping away everyone who didn't thumbs
up the video we learned that they were
instructed not to interfere and that
they were pretty much only allowed to
fight the deviant threat we get a shot
of an ancient invasion in what may or
may not be babylon and the fact that
they don't help out in this shows that
their hands were pretty much tied now if
this is babylon then this was shown in
the first trailer and due to the setting
it may or may not be the same i got a d
in geography so i don't know and the
mine esque temples could contradict this
theory however we do know that babylon
will be in the film and this could
actually be setting up kang who too
appeared at this location in the comics
icarus watches over a civilization
burning and this is murdered in a new
blast which follows in the next shot
cersei informs dane that they aren't
allowed to interfere unless the deviants
are involved and we learned that they
were given these instructions by the
celestials now i am torn on which one
this is and though it looks like east on
the searcher due to the mask i think
more likely than not that it's actually
arashem due to the red armor he was
actually the celestial leader and if you
look at the chess pieces of aeson and
this one side by side they are slightly
different so arushem is the one i'm
leaning into icarus says they need to
find the others and it's likely that at
this point he's clearly talking to
cersei because of the reply in which he
says she hasn't seen some of them for
centuries now they might be doing some
nifty trailer editing but we know from
the character descriptions that cersei
works in a museum and in the top left we
can see pictures that someone in this
profession would have could to wear
druid is which is a village the
character has the ability to control
people's minds and apparently he's been
doing this to the locals there to see if
he can carry it out on a grand scale
this is why there's people standing
around or wearing the same things and
he's pretty much a cult leader at this
point he wants to do this mind control
in order to see if there's a way to stop
war and he's lost faith that humanity
will ever be able to live peacefully
next is sprite and we then get a shot of
dina hitting gilgamesh who blocks it
with his energy powers kudu has seen
that the eternals have shown up to meet
her and they're now joined by kingo
kingo is a bollywood superstar actor and
he apparently travels with someone who
documents everything about his life this
is why in the teasers we saw him stood
next to someone with a camera and they
could also be seen when the group were
at the village a lot of people thought
that this was a mistake and that the
camera crew had been caught in the shot
but i think they're just probably part
of kingo's crew next up we get a shot of
a volcano erupting which appears later
on in the trailer i'm guessing that this
will be a big set piece in the film or
potentially it could be vesuvius and
pompeii and we might be seeing it in the
past this of course appeared in loki
during episode 2 and it may be linking
the two properties together or it may be
a reach fastos then joins them and he
will be played by brian tyree henry he
is the inventor of the group and
possibly the pilot of the ship as he's
the one who brings it back online it was
said in the character descriptions that
he's had a hand in a lot of humanity's
inventions and potentially he helped us
to create the nuke just after a detonate
he seems absolutely devastated i think
he may regret giving us a weapon so
powerful that will be used to hurt
others we then get a shot of drug and
makari the latter of which is the
speedster of the group behind them is an
ancient egyptian cat statue plated in
gold and in the first trailer we could
catch her surrounded by artifacts we
then get a money shot of the group
together in full i'm guessing that this
is what happens after they introduce
themselves on earth dina says that they
have loved us since they arrived and
instead of the trailer being all doom
and gloom we see sprite creating
fireworks for primitive man you may
notice that their powers are golden and
this is because they pull from cosmic
abilities which were of course set up in
captain marvel as we learned in one
division red represents chaos magic
purple is dark magic and orange is your
more typical standard magic so i like
that they're keeping things uniformed we
then get a shot of jolly old london
namely camden and see a double-decker
bus almost crushing dane but cersei
steps in and changes it to roses hope
the driver wasn't hurt in that now over
the top of this the narration carries on
and then says when you love something
you protect it this is interspersed with
shots of icarus and cersei protecting
dane setting up a love triangle between
the three we then get a bit where cersei
starts to ship up and also see what is
potentially jemiah the celestial might
not be but typically they tend to use
specific colours for specific characters
and he's always green now over the top
of this we get several shots of the
eternals fighting the deviants and these
include the fishing village as well as
druik's home we get a big look at the
main deviant who tells theena that she
can't protect any of them as always we
end on a joke at bastos's home in which
icarus jokingly says that the safe house
is probably heavily protected and he
guesses that the table is made of
vibranium this is of course the precious
almost indestructible metal that comes
from wakanda he smashes the table and we
learn that it's actually from the ikea
full collection now this is the perfect
time to let you know that we are
sponsored by the ikea i'm just kidding
i'll never be that big anyway this kind
of mirrors the first trailer in which
they were discussing iron man and
captain rogers being gone interestingly
they called him captain rogers and this
was of course because sam wilson is the
current one anyway that's the trailer i
absolutely loved it yeah i don't know i
know kind of there's there's mixed
feelings about this movie online but
personally i think they showed a lot of
things to us answered a lot of questions
and also set up the general threat
whilst teasing some of the mystery
that's gonna be in the movie i don't
think it's gonna be as straightforward
as this makes out and yeah let me know
if you agree with that icarus theory or
not as a thank you for interacting with
the video you'll be entered into a
competition at the end of the month in
which we're giving away three copies of
an mcu box set directly to you if you
win now all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the trailer the winners of
last month's competition are on screen
right now so if that's you then message
me on twitter at heavyspoilers if you
want something else to watch then make
sure you check out our breakdown of what
if episode 2 which will be linked on
screen right now we went through the
whole episode from top to bottom and
found all the easter eggs that we could
so definitely go check it out right
after this without the way thank you for
sitting through the video i've been paul
i'll see you next time take care peace